okay so today am I gonna come
integration by substitution where you
have to do with definite integrals okay
but just as one last question some of
you have done this by now I know because
some of you did it and you're like huh
okay in case you're wondering or you
haven't got that yet and how this is
done I know in this exercise they've
been providing a substitution for me
okay but let's just suppose they don't
because later on you'll have to work it
out on your own it's not that hard
what substitution would you suggest for
you let u equal Y plus 1 all right
that's fine now so fast and procedure
has been in order to get rid of Y right
I'm gonna have to differentiate this guy
that'll give me D U on dy rather DX I
got X's here right so in this case do u
1y alright that's that equal to
it's just one good so therefore the
relationship here is du u equals just dy
X and multiply through okay now usually
at this point this is enough you can
bring this back over you can make all
the substitutions you need okay but in
this particular example we're a little
short because when you start thinking
about okay I don't know what cost one is
I know what the dy is but then you're
stuck with this guy okay then usually
where does that come from usually wins
that tune
you know usually Kansas app because it
usually appears here or here or
something like that but in this case it
didn't work right so how do we get rid
of the why this time because we cannot
have pot wise and pot use we're going to
change the whole printer from one into
another so how do I get rid of this one
yeah ok good so there's a more
fundamental relationship here right you
come back to the original substitution
you made and it already has a wider with
no actual around so all I need to do is
shift that around until I can change the
whole question okay so this is going to
be a you sorry well I just need to do
whatever I can in order to change this
in from a question of company recommend
for a minute okay
right now this is the square so now what
should I do
do the thing with with the guy and the
staff Keith oh I should expand right so
it might be easier to see the expansion
if you recognize that that's just use
the power of uh-huh okay and then you go
to your powers lighting up so this is
either half minus you to the side yeah
three-on-two and that's you do you okay
then it's pretty standard from there
let's let's just for the sake of it
raise the power divided by the power and
raise the power and so now I just need
to finish off and read back to the wise
to Fields
so we going to okay now just before I
finally want to the definite interest
can I just use this as an option me
I've worked about I'd love to hospitable
bucks at this point okay and as I've
been looking through and especially with
the definite integrals when you come up
with some numerical error at the end
right what do you like done the numbers
just wrong sieves find out behind its
ergometer cuz it's a pain you've got to
get through okay now I can always
guarantee like I've picked up into eight
or nine errors and out of those almost
all that definitely one exception they
creep being in these steps here okay
there's so many little things that can
go wrong
for instance okay as you are raised your
power okay maybe if you've got saying
three to four or five to MC you mix up
which power is which so then when you're
adding one you know you do it to the
wrong power and one of your powers in
this line will be wrong then when you
get to the next one you evaluate in
Israel okay another common error is when
you go from here to here you're dividing
through you know you put five oh two out
the front instead of two or five okay
or you just flat-out forget to divide
okay so these little things you have to
be able to look for yourself right when
you get to the end you guys will be told
by the answer's no Caitlin value is
wrong okay button they say you don't get
told that it's wrong you just need to
look carefully on your own okay so lots
of silly areas creep in just make sure
you've got your own cross your T's